you know before your dad died he
revealed that he had all this
unreleased music he had this like vault
what are you going to do with this you
know the fans probably want everything
released
they think i'm here to talk about it now
you know
i'm sure they're chomping at the bit to
hear what's in the vault what's in the
vault
what is in the bowl a [ __ ] ton of tapes
that will take a very very long time to
go through
so it's not you know as disappointing as
it may be to
something here that's not the priority
right now i know it would be too painful
to go through it right now
absolutely yeah i think for right now
i don't know i can't put a timeline on
it but not in the immediate future would
we be going through
it uh right it would be weird yeah
because
your father just died my dad would be
pissed off at me really he'd be like
what the [ __ ] are you
go do your [ __ ] what are you doing don't
go through my old [ __ ] go do your new
[ __ ]
you know so mark my words there will be
a time that we go through it it's just
it's not right now and we want to do it
right whenever the time is but i i think
it'd be a little shameless to do it
right now it'd be milking
you know dad and everything with the
ideas that
probably aren't out there for good
reason you know he put out the good [ __ ]
exactly exactly there's a reason it's
sitting in a vault
you know but i'm sure there's amazing
[ __ ] in there there's got to be
you know there's going to be but at some
point we'll go through it but
not now and not for a while